New York City my hometown wants to stop
the spread of man spreading what is man
spreading what we've got some photos
that will illuminate you man spreading
yeah there it is it is when these guys
it's usually about guys which is why
they're calling a man's ring really
sitting quits the legs really really
while I look at the look on his face -
he's very excited that
yeah and it's putting your bags on other
seats or on the floor blocking off now
that one I thought was particularly odd
because there's nobody else near him so
that that time it's okay but generally
this feeling of New York City the
subways are very over packed there right
now they're building the second Avenue
subway which they've been trying to do
for like 20 years or something but
especially on the east side the subways
are always packed and these guys that
just sit out there and bags everywhere
and all that stuff so they're trying to
stop it and there's a new poster that is
telling people what to do dude stop the
spread please it's a space issue I
thought this was kind of interesting
because it is getting a little blowback
people are like they're interfering with
our rights we can do whatever we want
blah blah blah and you know common
courtesy you know my sister is seven
months pregnant in New York City I was
skyping with her last night she was
telling me how half the time guys don't
even get up you know she's like
extremely pregnant big girl and they
still like it's just so I just thought
this was kind of you know do we need to
litigate these things or is it just
common decency it's just rude and
selfish I mean if I were to put my purse
on the seat on my jacket on the seat you
would ask me to move them and you would
be right to do so because I don't own
the train it's a public space and I
should do what is fair and allotted for
me yeah what's the worst thing you ever
saw done on the New York City Subway or
on any sort of transit thing because
I've seen some pretty too my favorite
thing that's ever happened on public
transportation is a bunch of kids
fighting over a picture and word up
Magazine of Chris Brown what I don't
know that's just that's incidental but
that probably every day there was like
it was like what are they fighting over
that's my Chris Brown poster that's
right gone but I on on public
transportation I've definitely seen
videos of like drunken people getting
and I've seen personally like drunken
people passed out sprawled on the
backseat like three across and then
afterwards they had to pull the person
out of the thing like totally drunk but
other than that like I had to
demonstrate for my girlfriend yesterday
I was showing her this this story and
it's a real thing like I can't sit with
my legs like this unless I do like a big
like you're doing now I'm not you are
I'm building it together but I just did
the flippy before if you don't do the
flippy you're and then it's a testament
what are you saying so you say when you
sit down naturally your legs fly those
were except a lot of these are [ __ ]
but like I'm sitting like this so my
legs are going out that's not man spread
it let's I have to do a whole like
series of motions so you know it's to do
that so if if there is someone that
needs to sit I'm gonna do all those
motions it's gonna look weird but then
I'll get in position where I can sit
like with my legs
you know parallel to each other that
said I think the whole idea of we're
gonna put up signs that helps but you
can still like look at someone I mean
this is people in public transportation
trying to say like I don't make me look
at them and go can you please let me sit
down right so that's why I thought the
story was interesting because the I look
it's not a law they're not passing a law
you're not gonna get fined if you spread
your junk you're not getting it fine
although one time actually speaking to
spreading drug I did see a guy like an
old man in running shorts and he had no
underwear on his balls were just
literally on his old balls were just on
the subway there yeah just on the chair
just like that well I don't think he
knew like I don't yeah I don't think he
was a pervert or breathe feelings at all
he does that old ball he was cooling off
his old balls but actually that wasn't
even the worst thing that I saw on the
subway the worst thing I ever saw on the
subway was on a packed New York City
morning commute there was a woman
clipping her fingernails I mean
literally they would just fly everyone's
looking at her and in a weird way I
admired her now I was like if I could
ever be so detached and not give a [ __ ]
to the point that this woman I give way
too much of a [ __ ] this woman doesn't
give a [ __ ] and she's getting [ __ ] done
considerate of others besides yourself
for once especially if you're in public
that's what the sign is for try and not
be a nuisance but you were not the only
one here really there's a new there's a
new line there's a new like a Expo line
or something
and people on this stretch have never
used light rail before because it's new
it hasn't gotten there so what I saw
when it first opened up was a lot of
people that are like the opposite like
everyone staying as far away from each
other as possible and like they're like
looking around it's this is a new thing
I'm afraid of everything here right if
you go to a city with like a lot of
people on public transportation it's the
opposite it's just everyone is so like
in it and their personal space ideas are
just completely out the window and it's
as though they don't notice other people
around them yeah if you don't live in
New York City and you've never been to
New York City you want to know a little
bit about the craziness subway find the
episode of Seinfeld that Elaine is
trapped they're all on the subway in
that episode but Elaine is by herself
trapped on the subway and it's a perfect
example of how crazy the subway is but
my final thought on this is that how
much of this do you think is just a
culture of sort of the selfie and our
followings like we're all so into our
own [ __ ] all the time that I don't think
people really even realize when they're
in a public space like you're describing
there in a your transit thing and
they're so still in it so they don't
even realize what their body's doing you
see this all the time videos are people
falling into fountains do they have
their heads now like it's just part of
that culture that way well you know
we're definitely in our in our own [ __ ]
all the time but if you want to get in
other people's literal [ __ ] ride the
subway yeah yeah but yeah we're we're
definitely abled now you used to be
together like a nag magazine or a paper
and you're doing that and then you're
but everyone knows who's around them and
you do the thing where you like turn
away and lean so the other person like
that backs up and gets away from you but
close your legs if you're on the subway
that's it